you can say my underwear Swiss
you
look at each other guys
okay have you got a free hand behind you
okay grab someone's butt cheek and
squeeze the hell out of a go
and Sooners had a little bit crude but
you can't do this with your husband who
the heading to do it to right what I
want you to do is I want you to dance on
it a little bit so stay there now they
just trust men if you stay put okay
you'll get enjoy it a lot more same in
hold him and you know just you know rub
yourself on him a little bit a bit of
fun looking into it footing with a bit
of giggling bit of bit of animation
there there you go and [ __ ] up darling
chin up chin up chin up that's it close
to get with your faces there a little
bit that's it looking at her this is
kinky don't look at me
and looking into her which we're
snuggling with nothing we're having a
bit of fun there there you go that's it
beautiful
twenty-five more into Hurst let's see
then chin up a bit let's see it
beautiful
that's gorgeous hover there
alright guys what I want you to do I'm
gonna get you to walk this way so just
slightly separate so it's easier for you
to walk so men try to have up a little
bit make it laugh a little bit a bit of
fun with it
Oh girlfriend me I go
I give her a couple little levels of it
and don't chin up looking at that way
that's it and but I want to enjoy it as
well that's it here right up so I can
see it there we go and we're giggling
we're motorboating that's gorgeous soft
little smile this is just about to kiss
bring your left hand on the back of his
head there down and tilt your head
towards me gorgeous with you
all right perfect
moving day over the year I'm trying man
I'm trying to face in terms of the loot
let it stop there and foreheads touching
yeah beautiful guys over there don't
move either it made us write down in
that's it just let you see
bring the glasses together and lean
linic close to the candles that's it and
bring your hand down and on your right
head and go down that's it just like
that perfect now closer get together
soft little look together beautiful guys
I just actually make the noise so I want
to hear the sound a little bit Hagar
should hold the files at this hand and
very gently just hold the violin and an
excuse to be doing something there
shoulder back telling that's it that's
gorgeous
very gently now just turn your face to
your flowers that's it
turn your face more than right that's
integer eyes down that's perfect I move
this is like a dream it's all
quarter-sawed thank you so cool she not
believer there that's it beautiful and
looking down the road there do is sing I
believe I can fly
don't be really know how much this means
to you really know that kid thank you
enough you know what don't worry about I
think about me what you think about you
and your Daniel I mean I appreciate I
appreciate on sale I really do thank you
sweetie
Oh
you
you
beautifulness snuggle influence arching
and look down in towards about that's it
and might just whisper in her ear making
but Michael Arvin
now bring the materials close to you as
possible without touching it
instead of wring it quite tight as well
so if it really has to be closer
Finnish neighbor with mum a little tip
of the noses there
okay guys look look at each other say
they say say say
and then have you it who's your partner
honey would you like a point your
attitude towards me like this brought
you out of tote and then bend it and
then pressure we hit it back a little
bit that's it they hit back if you push
it towards me it'll make a little bigger
future reference you see you know the
photographs if you put your arm off your
body your arm looks slimmer and if you
put you your butt away from me it
actually looks small right your boobs
look bigger you put it towards the
camera I'm just saying
close your eyes same position exactly
close your eyes I know this sounds weird
but closer eyes again and you won't hear
my words here I want you to just tell
each other that you love each other just
by the way your your faces are touching
me hug each other love your faces here
really sad for you to watch quarters
unless you die I'm just huh okay
like for us
mission a temple in right that's it over
and close your eyes both of you don't
move don't move that moves that guys
this door just hold it and then you look
at each other lovingly like adoringly
yeah the tongue came at dinner they cut
the time no I can feel the aura a wind
rise expression we're in the south with
each other's lips we took you to the
right that's it now Lina back a bit wrap
you can free your right elbow bring it
out
look top that's a beautiful
did through the bottom sort of like in
the statue just a perfect away
Dominus gorgeous just relax your
shoulders a little bit funny that's
better
that's gorgeous all their eyes amigo
just and love me now as in smile
eyes at me
that's it awesome holder let's continue
with the face a little bit and then
we'll sort of work our way maybe a bit
more broader just without moving your
face just peel your eyes out this way
yeah it's you're not that's it the moon
that's it you keep that little bit too
awesome a bit be right back now turn
like that that's it turn your face more
this way good and just peer off Dave
tilt more that way chin up
all right when you ready twist it faster
oh yeah
I want you to turn your face this way
extreme that way
I want you to have the flashy LED light
that goes through there
cool cool
all right
so I want your bet here I want you to
she'll bet so doesn't I want just to
touch just attach the link just the way
you are I don't move a thing but just
pretend like you're a turntable and turn
towards this way stop face more left
okay you just point the flash everyone
directly this place is slightly on an
angle so just point it get it vertically
behind her yep
so go completely above and in the middle
if you can come a bit more towards me
like it yeah but you bit too above her
yeah there you go the lecture
beautiful don't move there darling it's
gorgeous hold it
now I'd like you to do with both your
hands bring this hand up so I'm shooting
through here and then turn it all the
way more that's better chin write it
down bit more gorgeous hold us really
hold a bear
that's a die head turn your face this
way
turn your face extreme left that's it
and chin right up beautiful bit more
line Tim all that way she right up and
eyes down perfect
tilt your top of your head towards me -
that's it and eyes down that's it
perfect look at that arch your back last
minute there beautiful
I'm going to get you to bring that hand
right up high just some last-minute ads
perfect to move let's see it perfect
gorgeous yeah here perfect eyes oh my
head is then in there perfect don't move
gorgeous don't move